[Music]
Miley Cyrus's new album younger now is
also out and she forgot country music
legend Dolly Parton to be a part of it
so in return Miley paid her godmother
the ultimate compliment
now Miley always just being Miley she
recently said dolly made country music
sexual better no it was hot
well maybe and back in the day you know
when I was you know I'd wear my my big
hair and my boobs sticking out know that
probably I don't know what she meant but
sounds all right to me take it at my age
I'll take anything at 71 years young
dolly isn't slowing down just yet
rainbow land recorded with her famous
goddaughter is vintage dolly through and
through
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a song we wrote together being
miles apart we would call each other
we'd see each other yeah [ __ ] soon meat
patches cuz I'm still an old-timer we
say more time lists than old-timer of
course the queen of country recently
made headlines when she stepped out on
the Emmy stage as a presenter with her 9
to 5 co-stars Jane Fonda and Lily Tomlin
it led to all the rumors will there be
another movie could there be a TV series
could there be a reboot with new women
playing your characters well they should
do that I think I doubt that we're gonna
do it you're out jokes now to do a
remake of 9:00 to 5:00 would be more
like 95 go squirt a little to be like
good bad news that is not true
now Dolly's doing something she's never
done before releasing her first
children's album proceeds from I believe
in you will benefit Imagination Library
her charity that's donated over 100
million books to children in need
you've never done a children's album
before so why was now the right time
well why not it's about time don't you
think to never have children yourself no
more reason when we first got married I
figured we'd have kids we had names for
them you know as you do when you're
dating you in your first marriage and
then life caught up and you know we just
never got pregnant but I really honestly
believe that some things like that are
meant to be because now everybody's kids
are mine right you're sort of the mama
for everyone taking care of all I'm the
dolly mom dolly mama I love that oh can
you be my dolly okay perfect she said
yes I'm getting the paperwork ready I'm
moving into the RV with you dolly yeah
but she'll be left out of the will
[Music]
you